So, what we're going to get out of feature transformation is
the ability to combine these features, these words, somehow, into
some new space where hopefully we will do a better
job of eliminating our false positives and false negatives by combining
words together. So, we're going to leave this example for now,
but just to give you an intuition about how a proper
kind of feature transformation might help you just let me
point out that if I type in a word like car,
you would expect, since I know what car kind of means. Let's say automobiles in
this case, I should pick up documents or
score documents higher if they don't contain the
word car, but they do contain the word
automobile. Or perhaps they contain a word like
motor or race track. Or Tesla, right, that
somehow words like Tesla, and automobile, and motorway,
and anything else you can think of that has
to do with cars probably are highly correlated or highly
related to cars in some way. And so, it would
make sense to combine words like automobile and car together
into new features to pick up documents that are
somehow related together that way. Does that make sense? So
that's the intuition I want you to think of for
the three algorithms that we're going to go over next. Okay?
>> Yeah, I could definitely see how synonymy is
going to be a win, when we index the documents,
if we include, well, if we map them down to a
lower dimensional feature space where one feature's used for anything sort of
car related. I'm not sure how that's going to help with polysemy, but
I definitely see how this feature transformation idea could be a win
with synonymy. The way, so that's right, and I think it's, it's
much easier to see how it works with synonomy then with polysemy.
The way it will, it could in principle help you with polysemy
is that it will combine a bunch of features that together eliminate
the ambiguity of any particular word. So as you type in
more words together it'll start to pick those thing up while also
eliminating synonomy. So we'll see. The way it's going to work in practice
actually is that if you think of it. Now we are talking
about unsupervised learning. But if you think of this as a
supervised learning problem, then you can imagine how you can ask yourself
how to combine sets of these features, these words together such that
they can still give you correct labels. And if you can solve
that problem you will end up solving both
polysemy and synonomy. Or at least minimizing their impact.
>> Cool.
>> OK. So let's go over this specific example to
far more abstract examples and talk about three specific algorithms. .